alors jean pierre mocky le 8 juin sort
un film qui s'appelle une nuit à
l'assemblée nationale c'est ce que tu
racontes en ce moment 1 sur toutes les
radios et sur toutes les télés
la promotion du film on emmerde faire la
promotion c'est à dire que comme je
tourne beaucoup j'ai peur un petit peu
que les gens
finissent pas en avoir main pareil là je
change de chaîne la menace est toujours
meilleure dans de vendre film trop
souvent envoyés à l'oreille comme les
sujets sont différents j'espère que les
gens se lassent pas mais non ça va ça va
pour le moment donc il faut c'est un peu
comme les chanteurs nous on a envie de
faire une promo parce que le spectateur
il ya tellement de films que spectateur
finit par s'y perdre et donc il faut
quand même lui donner un petit peu
libellé ce qu'on présente alors c'est
pour ça que je suis là et ça me fait
plaisir d'être là d'ailleurs
alors comme ça fait cinq films en deux
ans là tout le monde te dis que tu
tournes trop j'imagine plutôt ou
beaucoup alors oui les ricains à
l'époque les ricains john ford les
grands week-ends et caetera et clark
bible en 33 il a fait neuf films dans la
nuit mais s'est déclaré quand même parce
qu'à l'époque on enchaîne les films est
d'abord il n'y avait pas de télé il y
avait pas d y avait pratiquement rien
donc le cinéma trim nécessité il fallait
en faire beaucoup pour qui pour
alimenter les sables qui les filment
changer toutes les semaines on te
demande toujours si tu bat le pas ouais
mais bon allez bâclé ça veut rien et a
bâclé c'est d'ailleurs quand on prête
quand les mecs fignole drogba s'il ya
des films qui sont fignoler seulement
c'est chiant d'une fignoler parce que
quand on tourne trop longtemps les mecs
qu'il commence à s'endormir dans le rôle
il faut les prendre sur le vif c'est un
peu comme le reporter le mec qui prend
une photo dans la rue sicile il flashe
pas le type tout de suite c'est bien le
gars il prend des expressions il s'en
faut toujours gravier etc
il est mauvais donc moi j'essaye
d'attraper les mails sur le vif et c'est
ça qui donne le côté bâclé mais en même
temps c'est ce qui donne la vis à vis et
leos carax team et 36 semaines pour
faire son film toi t'es pas non parce
que les oléoducs arras m'amuse pas c'est
un godard qui ré longuement basse et
jean luc y va de la vie que lui c'est un
mec qui fait des trucs que les gens
comprennent pas mais ça va vite dans les
cachots où ils veulent et d'essence
voilà ça y est indications données un
crayon sur une nappe il dessinait tandis
que il ya des pannes qui peignait des
fleurs pendant des mois et puis c'était
une belle preuve malheureuse mais
c'était la rose qu'on voyait dans un
vase quoi ça n'a l'air elle est le
produit
quant à ckoi 28 film va se
ça va falloir anti m tu l'as manqué
jean-pierre jamais jamais un césar quand
même j'aime pas les jeunes à cannes on
va ce n'est pas à l'école on peut pas il
est déprimant quand j'étais à l'école je
n'ai jamais rien parce que pour un an
après il fallait vraiment turbine est
bien avec les propres est toujours à
l'heure etc
et moi j'ai jamais voulu avoir de prix
quand j'étais en classe donc quand je
suis dans leur villa n'en veut pas de
prix jamais d'avancé sur recette non
plus non plus qu ce camp a dit toute
façon mais qui l'est du pays où il y en
a plein oui et alors quand il dit qu'il
a la place ça veut dire qu'ils se
démerdent pour en avoir parce que en
fait dans notre métier ça médiers de des
merdes et systèmes b alors le système v
ça consiste à trouver du pognon parce
qu'un producteur on dit producteurs
c'est-à-dire produire quelque chose mais
ça veut pas dire filet pognon parce que
philippe oignons ces financiers rendus
qu'in c'est un mec ya pas de pognon qui
en pro c'est pas pareil l'instant hormis
des cinq ans après snobs et avait plus
qu'une telle étant dans un appartement
qu'elle est ressaisi vite et aller rue
de valois
tu te barres alors par malraux et 60 mm
voilà c'est pas mal an 61
ben oui ça m'a permis de ne pas sauter
on va passer par un film qui plaisait
pas pitié devenu un classique après mais
on passa c'est toujours le même problème
les films qu'ils deviennent les
classiques c'est des filles qui marchent
pas au départ alors minuit à l'assemblée
nationale en fait on va faire un peu de
promo la cinq semaines de tournage une
semaine de montage sud et maire de
sortir entre les deux tours des
législatives tu savais que mitterrand et
dissoudre
non non quand même je suis pas devin
parce que quand je vais faire mon rabat
aura dit vous aviez prévu le et elle l
est mais qui sait 36 morts dus aisé non
non c'est juste ça tombe quoi c'est un
coup de bol
bon là on attend ce moment avec tapis là
ça serait bien alors oui c'est en gros
je vais le raconter à sa place parce que
vu qu'il raconte toute la journée je
vais te jettent il est donc michel blanc
il a il a aidé son village qui s'appelle
d'avoir bike il a aidé son village
donc pour lui parce qu'il a faim camp de
naturistes rihanna d'ailleurs vite
granal à champigny à des mecs qui vivent
toute l'année dans des clans comme ça à
poil c'est complet il voudrait
d'ailleurs qu'être à poil toute l'année
et c'est à dire que leur problème c'est
qu'ils voudraient pouvoir les allées
prendre le métro à point c'est reda
alors idéal comme les com lesquels les
pygmées ou je sais pas quoi il en est il
serait cruel retourner vers le paradis
terrestre les arrêter ni aux parités
reste alors que ce type là se trouve
confronté à une arlette laguiller qui
évoque une maille en attendant voilà un
string rouge elle se présente sachant
qu'elles seront pas élus d'ailleurs la
plupart des mecs qui se présentent à
part les deux premiers qui savent pas
qu'ils vont ils savent très bien qu'ils
seront pas élus et alors à partir de la
paix cette dame qui évite d'ailleurs à
l'état moitié un petit peu
baal est ambivalente elle marche à voile
et à vapeur aller là une vie sexuelle
assez curieuse parce que c'est comme ça
patrons d'entreprises et un petit peu
bon masculine
et puis il ya pouvoir et qui fait le
royaliste avait pas mettre le front
national a entamé un voyage
voilà d'ailleurs atteint pour les
voyelles il se dit non parce que c'est
vrai mais en réalité il semble qu'il y
ait à kramer la liste un nom mais il ya
quand même un petit point commun c'est
qu'ils vont à l'église saint nicolas du
chardonnet alors tout ça les rouleaux de
les rejoindre parce qu'on dit la messe
en latin que les agents non c'est vrai
nom motion des gens des purs br pas des
pions mais dès les royalistes qui en a
très peu et ils sont même pas représenté
il se présente pas à la présidentielle
puisqu'ils sont ils sont contre le
président a tous un 3 l'a donc en
réalité ce prêt se garer belaid a trop y
croire et là ils montrent un trafic de
légion d'honneur qui a existé d'ailleurs
à la saisie d'un à la casse au t3 lars à
cause de ça oui alors donc j'y vois là
il est dans un trafic et puis
brusquement blanc et my en découvrant le
trafic qui veulent s'en servir cours
pour brune pour le dénoncer pour faire
une campagne pour donner un petit peu de
sel à l'heure à leurs déclarations à
télévision
je regrette pas pas sûr de la saga
d'acteurs quoi mais je joue de temps en
temps j'ai fait le pari de baudart quand
même moins eu mais là quand on doit
aider il faut savoir s'il faut on a
plusieurs
quand un mec qui a plusieurs cordes à
son arc un sportif qui peut se voir
boxer mai
joue mieux au football et au mes qui
jouent ces séances est bien la façon
dont ça s'est passé
je regrette bien sûr des gta glace de
jouer avec le bec avec des belles avec
lequel je prends contourner ailleurs
mais ça va venir et bébel était mon
copain et puis finalement bébel est
devenu très connu et moins je suis
devenu un metteur en scène disons que ça
me fait un peu de la peine des rétros
maintenant activement je me j'aurais
bien aimé être comme ça à la une d
c'est vrai qu'il fait les essais pour
une série x x gérard philipe quel rôle a
été beaucoup plus en place l'atelier
avait déjà qu'on est à un moment donné
que les membres ou les jeunes et voulait
un inconnu alors évidemment il a fait
faire des essais à pas mal de jeunes
bourges était et gérard était plus vieux
que moi donc il l'a pris parce que parce
que c'était une vedette et qu' il
fallait une vedette pour le film
autrement il ne se montrait pas donc
c'est la vieille histoire de du mec qui
finit par l'acteur on sait qu'on balaie
avec kaprisky qui devait faire a été
meurtri a lancé à janis il a free il
faut c'est un peu le même truc
spectateurs de rentrer dans le rang là
au nom parce que les sujets créé et
réparé au nom genre et pas récupérable
c'est d'abord j'aurais pas de césar j'y
réponds au festival de cannes et puis
j'ai tellement de films à faire j'ai
tellement de trucs à droite à gauche à
faire beaucoup de trucs c'est à quel âge
60 piges la non j'ai 58 ans s'est pas
tout à fait pour brest c'est presque 60
je sais pas encore mais je les aurai
dans deux ans mais trahi par le vent
non mes 60 ans ça veut rien dire parce
que
stone ilan avec la forme d'un petit les
morts et charles vanel avec julien
fournials à 95
donc ça veut rien dire aujourd'hui 60
ans et quand j'aurai 60 ans dans deux
ans j'aurais quand même fait 35 qu'il
pourrait enfin on perd autant